silently a steady stream of teenagers
came to mourn laying flowers at the
scene of yet another fatal stabbing in
the capital
just a mile away from this estate in
thamesmead police stood guard at the
location of a second murder this time in
Abbey Wood the boys aged just 16 were
stabbed within a matter of minutes of
each other
homicide colleagues are investigating
and are treating the two murders as
linked
I can assure everybody affected by these
murders that skilled detectives will
work tirelessly to discover what
happened and provide answers to the
young victims and families
the 999 calls began coming in at around
10 past five on Saturday afternoon
paramedics attempted to save the boy's
lives but both were pronounced dead on
the street
they've been named by police as Kiani
solanki who was killed in thamesmead and
Charlie Bartolo
by mid-afternoon dozens of people had
gathered close to the scene in Abbey
Wood to remember yet another Young Life
lost they licked candles and placed them
next to the flowers and balloons were
released into the sky
for both communities it's been an
unbearable shock ambulance they try to
do their best and I think Unfortunately
they have to lose the boy
but then he's very sad and since then
all all the people in the community will
be mourning the boy
the deaths come in yet another weekend
of violence across London despite a
targeted effort to tackle knife crime
figures from the metropolitan police
show violent crime with the blade was up
15 in October compared to the previous
month Anne-Marie cousins is the local
councilor for Abby wood
two 16 year old their babes two 16 year
olds think about that and give whatever
intelligence don't evaluate it whatever
it is any suspicions you have let the
police have it police want to hear from
anyone who saw a dark SUV or 4x4 type
vehicle with silver roof bars at either
location in the days before the
teenagers were stabbed as their families
become the latest left to mourn an
unbearable loss in an epidemic of
violence
Emma birchley Sky News Southeast London